Mike Florio on loan from pro football
talk.com and judging from the liquor
stash behind you in the bar Mike you're
doing pretty well well yeah not not not
yet though not this morning
it's still early but later today I'll be
doing very well well thanks for joining
us from the barn
the NFL's overall strategy here full
speed ahead
you know with the draft we're still
gonna have it was there any possibility
of them not having the schedule release
party this Thursday
well you know there was a report last
week that the league office had been
debating whether to delay it because
once you release the dates presumably
tickets are for sale do you get yourself
into a situation where you've got to
deal with processing refunds how do you
deal with all of that but the NFL
ultimately decided to go forward there
is a high level of optimism Dan that
they are going to get the season in now
well they have to delay it by a month or
so to accommodate allowing people to
attend games and as crazy as that sounds
there is confidence within the league
office that people will be able to
attend games they choose to do so that
the world will be very different come
September or October but there continues
to be this sense that this is what they
need to do there's a ton of money that
is riding on it plus they believe
they're doing a public service to those
of us who are desperate for sports to
return I was also wondering about this
because I think we both heard from
sources that you know there's a
truncated season let's say it's 12 games
or 14 games where do they take those two
games or four games from is you know
from non-conference the front of the
schedule back of the schedule yeah I
don't know at this point but it does
make sense to look at the schedule very
carefully when it comes out to look for
those clues that's the first thing I'm
gonna do there's been speculation that
the inter conference games will be the
first four weeks of the season and those
would be the ones that would most easily
be wiped out or maybe taken away and put
on that back end of the schedule dan I
think it is very possible that the
season would be delayed by up to a month
to accommodate the ability to have open
stadiums that politically it's going to
be delicate in states like California to
get the governor's to sign off on the
idea of letting anyone who chooses to
show up understanding the real
and and testing will be much more
prevalent by then it'll be easier for
people to know if they've had this virus
via antibody testing but if delaying in
a month allows every state that has an
NFL stadium to get to the point where
they'll say go ahead let people show up
if they choose to that's what they would
do and then I guess they could take
those first four games and tack them
onto the back end of the season if
that's what they choose to do but I'm
gonna be looking for that flexibility
that may kind of scream out from the
schedule the moment that it's released
and I was told that you know maybe we
pushed back the Superbowl but I was told
that the NFL would love to have the
Superbowl / Presidents Day weekend you
get that Monday off so now you have that
built-in holiday that people keep asking
for the unofficial day after the Super
Bowl what do you think about that
they've been trying to get the Super
Bowl to President's Day weekend for as
long as I've been covering the NFL I
think they really want to do it and an
18th game will do it but before we get
to an 18th game this is a way to bump
the Superbowl back a couple of weeks and
get it on President's Day weekend but
look and the mere fact that there would
be a Super Bowl this year given
everything we've gone through in and of
itself is a holiday so just getting the
season in getting the Super Bowl played
I know it seems weird now because we're
still in the early days relatively
speaking at this pandemic but I have
been told with a very high degree of
confidence that the world will be much
different come August and September and
it will be a lot easier for sports teams
to operate not like they normally would
but in a way that actually makes sense
and that that manages the risks of
people getting the virus he's Mike
Florio you can check him out Monday
through Friday 7:00 and 9:00 a.m.
Eastern and he's also on the Dan Patrick
radio channel that Sirius channel 211 a
best-case scenario for Cam Newton now is
what wait wait for someone to get
injured we had a graphic on the show
yesterday of all the starting
quarterbacks that were injured last year
remember early in the year Cam Newton
was gone week two Ben Roethlisberger was
gone
week two Drew Brees was gone week two
although he came back and I think for
Cam Newton at this point with all the
seats taken with the Patriots showing no
inclination to try to add him to their
depth chart you just
for someone to get hurt and you just
assume that it'll happen and if it
doesn't well you keep waiting but there
isn't an opportunity out there for him
he's not going to take the Andy Dalton
package of three million dollars minimum
plus the ability to make up the seven
moon he's just not gonna do that he's
gonna wait for someone to say cam you
are our guy and the other reality too
and this is what hurt him this year the
inability to go get checked out by a
team doctor because he's got the foot
surgery from last year the shoulder
surgery from the year before that caused
him to change his throwing motion Dan
that's how serious that situation was
he's got to get checked out before a
team will sign him and I think at this
point he should just wait until the
season starts and someone calls and says
we need you right now I had somebody say
this to me yesterday and they said what
about cam and Pittsburgh and I said it's
tricky because I don't that means what
about been with cam in Pittsburgh and I
don't know how long Ben is going to play
and if you bring Cam Newton to town it's
an upgrade over what you have but does
cam fit into what Pittsburgh wants to do
or it will be doing after the Ben eras
over and what's he gonna want
financially that's the other side of it
too and one of the things you have to
take into account is that if you bring
Cam Newton onto a team you you better be
secure in your starter because instantly
you're gonna have guys in the locker
room who look at cam and look at your
starter they look at cam they look at
your starter and it's not going to take
many practices before they start saying
cam is the better guy now in Pittsburgh
that's not going to be the case but I
think that's one of the inherent
problems of him being a backup anywhere
because he's better than most starters
so in Pittsburgh yeah it would make
sense to have a better backup I just
don't think it makes sense for cam to
commit to being a backup anywhere when
he can just sit back and wait for
someone to get injury we've been at this
a long time and we know how negotiations
go and you like that the cowboy
situation now borders maybe it is
embarrassing not borders on it's been
embarrassing with dak Prescott it feels
like there's a price and that's it
that's the price and if you pay the
price then we move on feels like
everybody else got their price dak is
saying this is what my price is
what is the price like what is the
holdup here where they just don't say
this is we're giving you 35 a year deck
here it is let's go let's move forward
well here's the lesson that all teams
can take from the Cowboys experience
with that Prescott the longer you wait
the more expensive it will get the
moment you know this is your guy pay him
and pay him now because it's not going
to get any cheaper the Chiefs need to be
listening to that as a relates to
Patrick Mahone's the Texans need to be
listening to it as it relates to the
Shawn Watson the longer you wait the
more expensive it gets and here's where
they are now it's very simple now Dan it
has nothing to do with the market
they've applied the exclusive franchise
tag to desks back Prescott that's 31
point four million this year a 20% raise
next year that's another six point two
million on top of the thirty one point
four that's almost thirty seven and a
half million dollars next year you put
it together at 69 million over two years
there's your 35 million per year right
there and if DAC those year two year by
year three 20 22 he's entitled to a
forty four percent raise over what he
makes next year you're talking about
astronomical numbers and the only
alternative is to let him hit the open
market so he has them over a barrel and
it's their own fault because they waited
this long so all he does is sits back
and waits and he's guaranteed 31 point 4
million this year the only the only
weapon the Cowboys have left and I don't
think they'll ever use it they just
rescind the tender and think about that
if they would remove the tender right
now and make that Prescott a free agent
who in the hell is gonna pay him thirty
1.4 million who can everybody's got
their starters so he would be screwed
financially if the Cowboys use their
nuclear option of saying all right we're
taking away the franchise tender you're
a free agent you wanted to be a free
agent go ahead and be one now good luck
finding a team
Andy Dalton signing was smart to have a
backup or leverage against deck well
it's smart to have a backup and here's
the other thing too let's say that the
Cowboys in tech Prescott don't work out
a long-term deal by the deadline of July
15 that's the annual drop-dead date for
doing a long-term deal with a franchise
tag player if you don't do that deal the
play
can still stay away from training camp
in the preseason at no financial penalty
because he's not in her contract
Le'Veon Bell did that in 2017 showed up
right before the start of the season
made his full franchise tag salary so
now they've got protection against dak
doing that because otherwise Cooper rush
was going to be your starting
quarterback for training camp in the
preseason now if that does stay away
they at least have Andy Dalton that they
can get ready to go and then it makes
for an intriguing decision if it plays
out that way Dalton is ready to go
he knows Mike McCarthy's offense dak
shows up a week before the first game
and says hey I'm here give me the
football Mike McCarthy may say we're
gonna go with the guy who's ready to
play at least for a week or two that
could make things even worse but it all
comes back to the Cowboys not paying dak
the moment they could after that third
regular season finale that's when the
window opens to pay a guy the sooner you
pay him the cheaper it's gonna be I'll
leave you with this with the Packers
plan the the overall game plan here give
me the strategy just cuz I don't I don't
understand it but you know you're
smarter than I am no no I'm not first of
all and second of all I don't know what
the hell the game plan is sometimes the
plan is there is no plan and it maybe is
basic as just trying to ensure that you
get the absolute best out of Aaron
Rodgers over the next couple of seasons
because he's going to be pissed off that
you went out and drafted his eventual
replacement Danny they invested a
first-round pick and a fourth round pick
on a guy who at best is a project with a
high ceiling but nobody knows where that
ceilings gonna be less than 20 months
after they signed Aaron Rodgers to a
four-year extension think about that
they've paid him almost eighty two
million dollars for 2018 and 2019
combined to have a contract that lasts
four more years with them now those four
years have been undermined by the
decision to not invest that first-round
pick in a receiver or someone that will
help the team win but in a guy who's
gonna take over at some point down the
road for Aaron Rodgers it makes no sense
to me and a point that Chris Simms made
that I think is just genius if they had
a real owner in Green Bay if they had a
Jerry Jones if they had a Jeffrey Loria
Robert
one person who signs off on these moves
would one owner have ever said sure go
ahead and draft a quarterback in round
one 20 months after you convinced me to
sign Aaron Rodgers to this massive
contract yeah that makes sense
well maybe I am a genius cuz yeah I said
the same thing on the show that chris
said that if you had an owner
I don't think if Aaron I think you go to
that owner like Tom Brady went to you
know Robert Kraft I I can go to you
there's a problem here or the owner goes
to the player and says something you're
run by a committee and I think that that
factored in to the Aaron Rodgers
situation I really do and Dan I also
think CEO Mark Murphy I think he
relishes that that just that with a
dysfunction and acrimony he thinks that
gets more out of Aaron Rodgers he said
it last year after that bleacher report
item came out that threw a lot of
gasoline on whatever was smoldering
between Rodgers and Mike McCarthy Marc
Murphy liked what that could mean for
the team and they went 13 and 3 so maybe
Murphy thinks hey let's piss this guy
off but a play better if he's upset oh I
think it's crazy but hey I press no
complaint woolley hey I think we don't
use the stories the stories choose us oh
that's why when Gronk wants to come back
sure come on I don't
I hope he's safe but if he wants come
back it's his life great you know I by
the way I I have to Tampa Bay t-shirts
left and if you would like one because
we were told to cease and desist we
can't sell them anymore I don't know if
you'd like to would you like a Tampa Bay
t-shirt I know I got it I got the
cease-and-desist your we heard from
Brady's law firm if we fought this Mike
now we came up with the idea for weeks
prior that we were we were gonna have
tompa bay t-shirts we tweeted it out we
built the shirt how would we have done
against a huge law firm well ii-i've
never fully researched the issue which
means I don't know what the hell I'm
about to say here but that's the reality
do you want to take on Tom Brady and the
legal muscle that
he would bring down on you and I really
do think I don't think Tom Brady has any
desire to market top abate t-shirts he
just wants to be able to tell everyone
else not to plain and simple so I would
not take on hashtag time all right well
thank you for that sound legal advice oh
whoa no by the hair the hair makes you
you know if I was giving you a hat I'd
give me a big hat between being trapped
inside and not being very far away from
the refrigerator and we get to the
barber I probably added 20 pounds and 18
of its hair your BJ Raji is what you're
saying there thank you Mike
that's Mike Florio Pro Football Talk